si la chef de l'exécutif hongkongais
espérait calmer le jeu en suspendant sa
loi c'est raté
kerry l'âme démission ce slogan a
résonné comme un mantra
les manifestants lui en veulent
notamment d'avoir qualifié d' émeutiers
les participants au rassemblement qui a
dégénéré mercredi dernier les rendant
ainsi passibles de peines de prison
et réclame des excuses pour ces
violences qui ont fait des dizaines de
blessés et un mort un militant qui
accrochait une bannière pour réclamer le
retrait total de la loi d'extradition
les opposants se méfie de cette
suspension à durée indéterminée
dans ces cas
ra de mettre en place
une loi liberticide et bien d autres
vraiment le dessin
la jeunesse des antilles
or ici aujourd'hui
la chef de l'exécutif car il a accusé
d'être sourde aux inquiétudes a dit hong
kong est de toutes les souches de la
société sur l'impact d'une loi
d'extradition vers la chine sur l'état
de droit les libertés du territoire
s'est excusé pour avoir provoqué des
conflits et querelles en présentant trop
peu trop tard elle ne s'est même pas
présenté devant une il n'a plus de
crédibilité assure cet artiste lâché
même par des élus pro pékin sur ce
projet de loi devenu gênant car il est
une leader prédit lisez ici en ligue b
repos et du canada hong kong